chair has been a music icon a fashion
icon a cultural icon for five decades
and no matter what crazy rumors you may
have heard she's not done yet as a
matter of fact in her world 70 is the
new 30 it's been 50 years since your
first song to chart on the Billboard I
know I'm just older than dirt no you're
not older than dirt in your mind what do
you think I feel like in my in my mind I
just totally forget and the other day I
thought I was 60 and I went oh my god
I'm 60 and I thought oh my god I should
just I never expected to live this long
she doesn't look or sound 70 but earlier
this year some tabloids printed that the
icon was close to death there all these
reports share SiC this may be her last
birthday they got a lot of mileage out
of that and like I was in San Tropez
eating ice cream like with my friends
they're taking pictures do they just
think I'm dying and I'm out here and
partying and all that so it sells
magazines alright gotta talk about your
love life would you ever get married
again I can't see any real reason for it
and I have you know I've tried to keep
it much more on the down-low because the
media is so horrible nowadays and so
mean and you can't do anything it's hard
for me to even go out of my door because
everyone's got a camera mm-hmm you know
and you and and everybody's in the
bushes and you know it's uh you have to
be it's like you have to steel yourself
every time you leave the house and sheer
fans rejoice she's returning to the
stage with a residency called classic
share that launches at the Monte Carlo
in Vegas and at the MGM in the DC area
beginning in February and expect her to
perform all her greatest hits and also
to recreate this incredible moment
your last show you did a duet with sunny
yes will you do that again yes what are
you thinking when you're singing with
him again we were so in tune you know we
weren't always perfect for sure but we
were so in tune in some way that if he
came back right now we would go we would
go riff and have each other's back and
it would just be the same on at this
point in a lot of people's careers
they're winding down you're winding back
up why because I like what I do you know
and I never knew there was gonna be like
a sell-by date no because I was young I
started when I was 16 it just never
occurred also it never occurred to me
that I would be doing this or than
anybody would want to see me do this and
the one thing I know is I still like to
sing so much